what's up everybody welcome back to the
game spot cross kind of funny live show
on gamespot.com slash e3 I'm Greg Miller
this is the pride of Long Island Kyle
Moriarty and these guys are Naughty Dog
Bruce Straley Neil druckmann the name of
our bags making video games
congratulations on the Uncharted 4
reception everyone loved your demo you
do thanks man
yeah we're happy that people are liking
it yeah and we're happy that it worked
and Bruce was able to play it I'm happy
I'm still alive so tell me what let's
run through this of course at the Sony
press conference a technical mishap
happens yeah what exactly went wrong
mate just frozen his steps video games
man there's technology you never you
can't trust it yeah I know I know okay
so I'm heading on stages bill with the
chair I got you know I'm gonna sit on a
chair and play make myself comfortable
of course and lady who's operating the
curtain the assist stages as you watch
out for bill the chair guy I'm like okay
cool so I'm walk it out and I'd look out
on the stage where the controller
supposed to be is not there and I hear
bill the chair guys excuse me I'm like
wait controllers not there what is the
controller excuse me controllers not
there where's the good and I dig down in
the well excuse me I gotta put the chair
and I'm like okay get out of Bill's way
it sets a chair down I dig into the well
there's cables and all sorts of stuff
down just shenanigans yeah find a find a
controller am i go gay I hope this is
the one I pull it up and I start the
demo everything's working great demo
starts am i cool I'm gonna settle in my
chair thanks Bill so then when it's time
to actually move Nathan Drake through
the marketplace I hit the analog stick
Nathan Drake doesn't move all right what
have they didn't move my mic Nathan's
not moving why aren't you moving it now
I'm like camera cameras not moving
what's happening there's a backup
monitor over here I'm thinking that
there's a joystick I'll pick up that
joystick now I'm not thinking straight
right gone into some other dimension
before all this they're asking us okay
what should we do if there's a crash or
something like it's not gonna crash it's
perfect like I'll just walk off so
you'll know if it's gonna crash but it's
gonna work fine so now I have two
controllers in my hand
I'm just jiggling every stick and
hitting every button nothing's happening
I'm like oh my god this is not good
the thought races through my brain it
says just walk off
you can just walk off I was like ignore
that thought then I hit the PS button on
both of the machines and I get the OS
over on the backup so I'm like okay well
there's something surprisingly the
primary did not respond at all nothing
happened so the controller somehow died
just to controller died who knows magic
like some wizardry somebody like put
some interference on me as a pawn Mesa
voodoo I pick up the other one on my
please God please I start the start the
demo I'm pointing at this one apparently
the guys in the booth are watching both
the monitors it's like Bruce hat Bruce
has the backup he's getting feed off the
bag he's picking up the second control
the second controller is a check we're
gonna run with the second one it's like
we got three drops of gas left where you
and I get this moonshot perfect it's
like we're down to one drop one drop
like everything's calm and cool I'm up
there freaking out pick up the other one
and it's time to move and I put the
joystick forward and the analog stick
and he moves and I'm just like
everything from that point on is just
cake yeah there is no stress at all it's
like yeah we gonna run through a demo
guys it's cool
it was awesome to hear the crowds
reaction when they just took a step
forward right right right right well
you've had that PSX the same thing
happened right when you fell through the
world and the crowd went crazy yeah
because that's what I think the
PlayStation audience wants right they
want legit demos and they let they
understand that you know and a heart
attack so many games is like death of
Game Director for sales here just to
make a video but we go to such lengths
but make it a live demo and stuff like
this can happen was it important to do
live demo I think it's just to show it's
a real game you know you're seeing the
game up there like and horrible things
can happen that's part of like the fun
of giving giving Bruce a heart attack
it's also kind of it's legitimately the
PSX demo and this one really made us
focus in on core mechanics water
mechanics are pair away all the
superfluous ideas that we've been like
kicking around a lot of theory craft
about like well we're gonna make this
game and it's just like what is this
thing sure so like rip it apart and come
down to like okay we're gonna make a
level we're gonna make it work we're
gonna make our AI work we're gonna get
into stealth how would we do in stealth
this time we're exploring all of those
things and it's making us it's for
as to make decisions and so we're coming
out of these two demos with so much more
tech and so much understanding and tools
and now we have an idea anybody on the
team and anybody out there can look at
these two demos go like I know what
uncharted 4 is like where it's heading
this is gonna be all it's it's the heart
of Uncharted we're showing you here this
is a core mechanics and it forces us to
make decisions so when you look at that
Jeep and I Drive like that's that's us
driving it that's like that's Bruce
have-not unreal and it's all physics
driven we're like at first more like
what what could go wrong and some
wouldn't do it I think the worst idea
physics is so unpredictable and it just
was this yeah
it forced us to really lock down the
gameplay and make the hard choices going
forward yeah I'm curious you know how do
you guys shoot you guys are like the
Greg and Colin of Naughty Dog and I mean
that is a compliment not an insult that
it probably comes off as how do you guys
decide who's gonna play because it's
always really you that ends up going up
and playing so like you guys have the
you know with the Last of Us and now
with Uncharted both times how do you is
it are you kind of the go-to for they
for the gameplay demos or do you want to
get kind of step up there and do it no
Bruce is to go too I'm too much of a
[ __ ] if that happened to me I would
have fainted or ran out crying I don't
know I don't know how it comes about I
think it's just like I I like I like I
like going up and presenting what the
team's been working on and I feel very
proud to do it and I feel very capable
of like I kind of want to show off so to
speak for the team and let in and I feel
capable and myself so I'm like all right
I'm just gonna I'm gonna do this I think
I'm done
I think that might be it for me but I
think that I've had this this one I
wanted to go up there and have
redemption for the PSX demo quite
honestly I was just like redemption is
mine and then I get up there like are
you kidding me right when you got up
that was the iconic you're lit you look
like it's like the start of some heavy
metal music video people people call
that out is like Bruce's stance like
what's Bruce gonna do this time
I'm trying to be comfortable first of
all it's the worst play experience that
you've ever been
you don't playing Stan who plays a video
games standing up nobody it's just like
unless you're like using an adjustable
wand or something like that right the
monitor is about this big it's down
below your feet and all I was trying to
do is spread my feet so I could get
lower to the monitors see what's going
on man
I'm all these eyes don't work like they
do but instead I mean what you look like
the most badass game developer anyone it
works out front of my favorite yeah that
was pure naivety that demo was just like
me just going up like yeah I'll try it
now has it been you know you guys
obviously have a lot of experience with
Uncharted but you don't previous Cammy
did was the Last of Us and with that it
was a new IP no real expectations apart
from the fact that you guys released
great games but no one knew what to
expect with that and you exceeded I
think wildly everyone's expectations one
of the great games of all time I think
is there a lot of pressure we were
talking about this before we went on is
there is there some sort of pressure
going back to Uncharted which is
something that's established in our
expectations with this particular
franchise there's always a ton of
pressure and you know I wish we could
say oh no you don't care you're just
doing the games you want to make and
there is a part of that we are making
the games want to make but we were
talking about it the other day the
pressure comes from like we want to make
the team proud like more than anything I
could care less for reviewers say or
what people outside nah dawg we're like
I want the people working on this game
to be proud of what we make and to know
that we're leading them somewhere
spectacular that and then for us it was
just really kind of taking a step back
from the last of us go it has a tone
tone its own feel looking at the three
previous titles to really kind of get
back into that world and it was a
process for us to get back into that
world into that tone oh yeah was that
hard
I mean you figure like Last of Us is so
dark and so it leaves a fingerprint on
your soul I feel like you lose part of
yourself to it and now to come back to
Drake goddamn Dorado and everything I
like you know what I mean like it's that
pulpwood adventure right was that hard
to change your mindset no I guess cuz
you know you're working on a game for
last most was three and a half years
that were just kind of in that world and
it's kind of like a breath of fresh air
to step away from that and to go back to
the epic to go back to the ethical to go
back to a jump button to go back to a
jump until I cranked it up to 11 and
then like see what okay with the stuff
we learned from the Last of Us of how we
can rely on allies both in story and
gameplay and bring that to uncharted you
know and those are all things we learned
from uncharted that we brought the last
though it's just an evolution of how we
make games I will say in the theater
room yesterday playing the extended demo
which is ridiculous I don't know you
guys seen like we said Cisco
see it Cisco liked it one of my company
there's a difference in the way we the
the attitude in the room even with us
when we're talking about this game seems
to be like yeah this is awesome like The
Last of Us dead you know we're 100% in
this thing we know what we're after we
have this thing but we're also like
really full of questions like yeah we
have e3 we have this demo back for for
the first tillu III three years ago
whatever and it was like it's heavy and
we're talking in that kind of like this
these are the kind of things that we're
trying to do philosophical [ __ ] like
that comparison is just like everything
even look at pictures just like oh this
is what we're trying but we're also full
of questions are like how are we gonna
pull this thing off is this gonna work
like we have an idea but uh and this one
it's like alright we know and when
you're watching this demo and you're
playing this demo you're just like
woohoo yeah and then you get to talk
about it usually like Uncharted awesome
like it's it's kind of that and it's
still like the character in the heart
and the depth and everything we're doing
we've expanded the core mechanics we
have so much richness in our in our
toolkit and that's a lot of work it
seems like we don't innovate because
it's like triple-a blah blah blah but
there's a lot of thought and a lot of
discussion and a lot of work for the
record I don't know if anybody's ever
looked at it and said you don't innovate
it's a perception thing but it's for me
at any rate it's all good
it's to me it's it's like I'm happy with
where we're at and I'm really excited to
talk about this game and it's fun to
play this demo and be back in the heart
of Uncharted and be like right we're
allowed to crank it into 11 we're
allowed to have a romp an adventure and
be Nathan Drake again it's awesome
it's fun it's there a level of
excitement with PlayStation 4
specifically that you have like really a
whole new audience obviously PlayStation
3 gamers have jumped at ps4 but ps4
seemed to have a really broad appeal and
a lot of people never played Uncharted
before and so they're gonna get the
Uncharted collection this fall and then
they'll play Uncharted for next year is
there an excitement that now you're
gonna reach not only the the PlayStation
nerds like us but now a whole new group
of people to kind of you know bring them
into the no II don't like what you guys
do an audio dog and and what you guys do
with Uncharted is it's not across your
minds at all that that ps4 is out there
in a lot of people's hands
I don't know if I think too much of I
don't think about we're just trying to
make an awesome game I will say our
approach run charge for he's been like
let's make a story that could stand on
its own it's got its own art but at the
same time it's a payoff for all the
three games that came before it and it
has to work on those two levels so on
that way you only haven't played the
previous three games are gonna get an
experience but if you have played those
games and you've seen their relationship
with Nate and Elena and slowly evolved
over those games you're getting that pay
off with uncharted 4 so I'm glad you're
talking about a story now I'm glad you
haven't mentioned Elena Fisher of course
best character in video games
my question is you keep making I keep
seeing these headlines pop up on the
news sites and your Destructoid's and
your whatnots saying Neil druckmann says
we're sending Nate out with a bang this
is what's what's this are you really
getting rid of Nate here is this the end
of the Nathan Drake story why would you
end Nate story don't end a story if you
let him get married and be happy that's
what I want to know then start the Elena
story but don't kill Nate don't don't
let Nate go away don't stop doing I'm
sorry it's gonna start some addition
hashtag CV mate I don't know I just from
what we discussed from what the story
where we fell we had to go and his arc
and where we could take it that felt
like there was one last place we could
go and this is the final chapter
Nathan's big story that's awesome it's
what I mean it's it's so bittersweet in
a way because we love Nate but what I've
always talked about when I talk about
Naughty Dog's legacy is the fact that
the company seems to leave things and
start new things you know I mean like
you can still make jak and daxter and
all this different stuff right now but
it would be like after you see what you
can do with Last of Us what you can see
with Uncharted wouldn't we want naughty
like and still be making that's a yet
don't you could but you shouldn't ya
know so I'm curious you know the
Uncharted collection itself he's
crushing unlock from the beginning can I
get all the I can I get all the trophies
and I get the platinum in each one of
these babies wants it thank you done
knocking check box I'm done what I was
gonna ask about the Uncharted collection
was that blue points doing the board
very capable you know studio but you
guys internally did the Last of Us port
the ps4 to kind of learn the
architecture was there any thought to do
the Uncharted collection yourself not
necessarily your team but internally or
it wasn't an obvious thing these are
three
we really don't have the time to deal
with this and you know Sony it was real
obvious we're yeah we can't do that yeah
we need to focus on just doing this
uncharted 4
yeah there's no way I mean even with the
Last of Us there was a debate whether we
should and a big part of the decision
like you mentioned was let's get to know
the architecture we already have a
benchmark like here's the the goal of
what we have to hit it was you know we
can go from there yeah it was great to
do remaster T loo remastered it really
gave us a leg up on on getting Uncharted
the first PSX demo I mean I don't think
that we would have hit that how do we
not had the tech and the tools and
everything that were were created in the
remastered are you guys playing like now
that you've you know I know how hard
your team works at Naughty Dog's
arguably the hardest-working studio and
I've been are you guys have been kind of
let me spend some time there and I got
to see kind of the way you guys work and
think and and you guys crunch and you
work really hard and as you know as you
guys were talking about making vertical
slices it's very difficult and yeah kind
of to put the team on to this one thing
to make everything polished and perfect
are you guys gonna kind of go dark after
this or is there in terms of you know
showing it in our soul well that was the
last one you guys are back out and happy
again but in terms of you know taking
the team off to make another vertical
slice to show it you know in Paris or
something like that or it's the
mentality now like what's what's you
know button down and get this gig the
game yet make the game that we haven't
talked too much about it but for me it's
it's about get the game done yeah let's
I think we got everything
as far as gameplay that we need I think
we got a course and we have the
everything's mapped out we got a lot of
the game done and a lot of game left to
do and let's just get it done
yeah but I'm happy I'm happy with where
we're at right now there's a big part
with multiplayer that we haven't
revealed yet and that has to come at
some point yeah I'm with Bruce we need
to just finish this game and get it out
there okay oh wow it you were saying
that you know these haters out there I
want to say you're not innovating you're
not doing difference of for you what are
the biggest gameplay changes cuz that
the PSX demo that was what we're calling
and I sat down and watched it again and
did the real my theater Mike they're you
know they're going back into patrol
modes and they're not just chasing maybe
the entire time and the oh yeah you've
heard this story what's this then we're
at the PlayStation we're here at
PlayStation experience we're watching on
the big screen in every five
minutes how's it going are you [ __ ]
seeing this are you but like you know
the fact that thank you there's now the
grappling hook there's now the ability
that it looks like enemies will go back
to Patrol if they can't find you there's
hiding there stealth like are those the
biggest changes and that's why you use
them or their other stuff under the hood
we don't know about in terms of like
what's different about uncharted 4 on a
gameplay wise and we have some more
stuff that we haven't seen um you
haven't even seen the problem-solving
and the the the rope is so dynamic I
mean here you're seeing it more and if
you see the extended you see it I guess
at the end of the change you know it's
so versatile and it could be used and
traversal it can be used in
problem-solving and reuse and puzzling
and we use inside of an action set piece
like we're doing so you know
everything's wrapped kind of core
mechanics are are enveloped in this
whole thing and it's the set piece now
is like everything's on the stick we
have more mechanics to show for sure
whether we show them maybe and who knows
how we're gonna reveal it right if not
just wait for the game but go dark we're
gonna go super dark dark black out man I
think surprises are so important you
know especially for hardcore gamers that
are following every bit of news that's
coming out now when you played on
charred 3 it was a spoiler if you
haven't played collection but there was
you know you there's a sequence there
that we purposely didn't reveal when
you're the last of us we didn't reveal
that you play Ellie and we want those
moments if you don't gonna walk away
from before be like that was awesome I
did not expect that at all so yeah like
you gave the spoiler didn't spoil
uncharted 3 but you had your chance I'm
curious since you know you guys are so
well-respected in this industry you guys
are great visionaries and great minds of
gaming what are you seeing at the show
that's impressing you are there any
other games that you guys let me jump
back to that last one real quick cuz I
was just thinking about it like one of
the difficult things that we struggle
with that I think every game tries to
get right is like if you're gonna create
a rich story and characters that you can
actually believe in in a world that they
can exist in then you have certain
constraints placed on game design but
you're still trying to make an
interactive experience that has all the
depth that allows the player to feel
invested meaning like the challenges
that we put in front of you in layouts
and designs an enemy design and
bosses of enemies into the turret truck
etc you have to be so familiarize with
your core mechanics and and adroit
dexterous on the stick and so
familiarized with that language of
interaction with that that world that
we're creating that you need to feel
empowered as a player and to take those
two things together of like how do we
create a really rich interactive
experience that empowers it gives you a
sense of choice but also an
understanding of where your choices lie
and at the same time fulfill the
character requirements the pacing as an
explorer bead is it is it a high tension
bead am i under a lot of pressure and
then the downbeat in the character like
that we're trying to feel sadness how do
we elicit those times of emotions with
this toolkit of layout enemy design core
mechanics ropes problem-solving like our
core tropes of what we're playing with
us in this thing so to take those two
things and constantly bounce back and
forth between does the story need to
change to help out the the gameplay does
the gameplay need to change to help out
the story and how to look at those two
things and make the sacrifice the hard
sacrifices because we want to do
whatever we want to make jetpacks we
want to make laser beams want to make
off those ideas are simple but to
actually go like what's gonna create the
most rich experience and keep the pacing
so it keeps that action cinematic feel
that uncharted is known for so being
innovative and trying to create the set
of new mechanics you know the Piton you
saw in the PSX so did you see the pizza
on no they don't have it
yeah pulled out of the wall and then you
climb oh yeah I see I called it the old
rock Stamper the old rock step the ol
rock stabber is there the ropes now you
have a Jeep you have all these kind of
new mechanics and then it's like
layering them on top of each other
keeping the pacing so that you're still
right there with Nathan Drake and
feeling what he's going through and and
there's a pace to it it feels like when
you're done it's just like oh man let's
go back for a second you forget that oh
my god that was like eight hours ago I
was back in that level at the begin of
the game I I forgot all about let's do
this again and that's what it's like
that's what we want to maintain with
uncharted 4 mechanics and sequences
there were kind of more of a downbeat
slower moments and uncharted anything in
Last of Us that we've done that you
can't show them off at e3 that in a
setting like this sure and it really
best left for the game itself yeah
I'll have you know that I think Bruce
use the word adroit it didn't answer
yeah which I appreciate sorry about that
kinda funny whose is big words
Nick Tim and I are like so but I am
curious per my previous question if
you've seen anything here that impresses
you B's I feel like this has actually
been a really pretty good III for some
some new games and some games we've seen
before horizon look pretty cool cuphead
looks pretty awesome so I said you guys
seen anything that impresses you as game
designers there's a game called The Last
Guardian no it's pretty much oh that new
that new I was telling you earlier
cuphead yep just to look at that game
the animation I want to get my hands on
that all the more fun stuff I'm kind of
blown away by everything quite honestly
there's a lot of games a lot of amazing
stuff like right now everybody's got
their handle on the technology we've
been in the theater all day yesterday
doing demos for people in interviews and
whatnot and then today same thing so
tomorrow we'll actually be able to like
walk around and check out things so who
knows I don't know just check it all out
go all right so we're wrapping we're
winding down the couch great no Hobie
cop just hold me call no all right so I
want to give you guys one of my your
game under charted for what kinda funny
improve okay so you ask this white white
Bruce place why is it your face
oh no we each got three Oh see like so
they're like Nick did not give you an
award Nick only plays axiom verge so he
did Nick plays axiom verge the shovel
knight neither of those games are at the
show this year so yeah we get to go put
a put them and put them around the place
let you know what we have over all right
game we have an overall game of the show
we've never shown this this is the most
important and covenant of all work yet
it is the least flashy of all the awards
we want we want this award to speak for
itself
it doesn't need a face cream so we would
be doing a viewer disservice and
congratulations if we didn't ask you
what makes Naughty Dog's so special
that's what I titled this little section
how do you guys keep doing this you keep
making amazing games you don't [ __ ] it
up and
was waiting everyone's like maybe this
no this isn't the one they [ __ ] up
Ocampo Santo I want to see that talk
about games seems different than most
people I think so much is the culture
that's been cultivated over many many
years where everyone is encouraged to
criticise and speak up when they see
somebody don't like so like even when
we're reviewing this demo day in and day
out we being are we have a large theater
and we're all sitting there and
everywhere everybody that's part of like
each section of there and they're all
speaking up they're all so you wait that
grass cue better that effect to hear
that dialogue that exchange that wasn't
very funny likewise that's kind of
shitty the jeep-like would await bumps
in the wall so everyone is constantly
criticizing the game it's horrible
helping making it better
and it just makes you feel like [ __ ] but
the game is better off for it
that's I don't it's it's funny because
they really are hard on themselves we
saw that with the Last of Us you know
how hard you guys were on yourselves and
I love the stories that you told about
how the game came out together at the
last minute you didn't you really didn't
realize how good the game was true
because you guys are so in it and that's
why I have that's why I was saying
before I don't want to see any more of
the game I have every confidence
considering your track record that the
game's gonna be fantastic the demo
started at the press conference a call
put his head down so I think you guys
were out you know personally think you
may be a little too hard on yourselves I
understand how it can be when you're in
the trenches with your team and and all
those things so you know but the demo
was on the show floor of the e3 so in
your face PlayStation for 2016
thank you guys so much stay for here
kind of funny stay more well you're the
one who's the big words
you